Día 7 de enero del 2020.
Primera hora de la tarde en Nueva York.
Salta la noticia: al menos dos docenas de
misiles balísticos contra posiciones estadounidenses.
Concretamente el objetivo fueron dos bases
militares iraquies en las que se encuentran
desplegados cientos de soldados del ejercito
de los Estados Unidos.
(Claro que todo esto no es más que la continuación
de una escalada en la tensión entre Irán
y Estados Unidos que tuvo su punto álgido
el pasado 3 de enero de 2020.
Ese día el ejercitó de los Estados Unidos
lanzó un fulimnante ataque nocturno sobre
un convoy cuando esté abandonaba el aeropuerto
de la capital iraki.
Dentro de ese convoy viajaban 2 personajes
muy importantes en la geopolítca de Oriente
Medio:
Por un lado el poderoso comandante de la Fuerza
Quds del Cuerpo de la Guardia Revolucionaria
Islámica de Irán, Qasem Suleimani.
Uno de los pesos pesados del regimen teocrático
de Iran.
Y junto a él, Abu Mahdi al-Muhandis, jefe
de la milicia iraquí Kataib Hezbollah, una
milicia fundada en 2003 para luchar contra
las tropas estadounidenses desplegadas en
el país.
Según la información del Pentagono, la operación
se llevó a cabo siguiendo las directrices
del propio Presidente de los Estados Unidos,
Donald Trump)
Ahora bien, ¿Quién era realmente Qasem Soleimani?
¿Qué significa su perdida?
¿Por qué Trump tomo la decisión de acabar
con su vida?
¿Cómo y por qué Irán ha lanzado misiles
balisticos contra posiciones norteamericanas?
Y, amigos, la pregunta más importante de
todas: ¿Qué puede puede ocurrir ahora?
¿Estamos acaso a las puertas de una guerra
entre los Estados Unidos e Irán?
Atentos.
No hablamos de cualquier personaje sino precisamente
de uno de los grandes protagonistas.
A ojos de Occidente, el Darth Vether, el Joker
o el Hans Landa de la política internacional.
Amigos Qasem Suleimani era el lider militar
más importante de Irán y quizas el segundo
lider más poderoso de todo el país, tan
sólo por detrás del propio lider supremo,
Ali Jamenei.
Y cómo ya os hemos contado en VisualPolitik,
Iran es uno de los archienemigos de los Estados
Unidos.
Así que… Blanco y en botella
Pero… Para entender realmente quien era
Qasam Suleimani, tenemos que comprender cómo
funciona la peculiar estructura militar de
este país..
Irán no tiene un ejercito sino que en la
práctica tiene dos ejercitos que funcionan
de forma independientes.
Sí, sí, dos ejercitos.
Fijaos.
(Por un lado está el ejercito común, un
ejercito que cuenta con algo más de 350 mil
soldados y que según el artículo 143 de
la constitución irani es el responsable de
ls funciones típicas:
la protección del territorio, el control
de las fronteras, la seguridad de las infraestructuras
esenciales, etcétera, etcétera.
Y por otro lado está la Guardia Revolucionaria,
que es un cuerpo independiente que se creo
en 1979, tras la revolución islámica de
Jomeini precisamente para defender la revolución.
Entre otras cosas de un posible golpe de estado
del propio ejercito.)
[Vamos, que además de las purgas habituales,
como los ayatolas seguian sin fiarse de nadie
pues se montaron su propio ejercito.
No sea que les pasará lo mismo que al Sha.]
Desde entonces su peso no ha parado de crecer.
Hoy es todo un ejercito con unos 150 mil efectivos
que están mucho mejor equipados, mejor entrenados
y mejor financiados que el ejercito irani.
De hecho esta Guardia no responde ante el
gobierno, sino directamene ante el lider supremo,
es decir ante la autoridad religiosa.
(Pues bien, dentro de esta Guardia Revolucionaria
encontramos una división autonoma, la Fuerza
Quds, que es algo así como una mezcla entre
lo que sería la CIA y los cuerpos especiales.
Es decir, un cuerpo de élite e inteligencia
que se encarga de todas las operaciones en
el extranjero.
Hablamos de la punta de lanza, la joya de
la corona, de la República Islámica de Iran.
El organo responsable de extender los tentáculos
de Irán más allá de sus fronteras.)
Y ese amigos, ese es, precisamente, el cuerpo
que desde hace 22 años dirigía Suleimani,
lo que le había convertido por así decirlo,
en el cerebro, el arquitecto del creciente
peso de Irán a lo largo y ancho de todo Oriente
Medio.
Con el paso de los años este personaje se
convirtió de facto en el responsable de toda
la política regional de Irán, lo que junto
a su control sobre las redes de inteligencia
y su cercania al lider supremo hicieron que
en la práctica Suleimani fuera más importante
e influyente que el propio Presidente del
país.
De hecho, ¿Sabéis como se refería a él,
el lider supremo, el ayatola Jamenei?
Pues… Ni más ni menos que como “un martir
viviente de la revolución”.
Y es que lo cierto es que este tipo supo hacer
su trabajo realmente bien.
Tan solo tenemos que echar un vistazo a cómo
le describen algunos halcones de Washington:
(Durante dos décadas, Soleimani ha sido el
terrorista más poderoso, inteligente y efectivo
del planeta.
Ha disfrutado del pleno respaldo del poderoso
estado terrorista.
Insustituible.
Mark Dubowitz, director ejecutivo de la Fundación
para la Defensa de las Democracias)
Al frente de la Fuerza Quds, Soleimani ha
tejido una red multinacional que durante los
últimos años se ha convertido en todo un
quebradero de cabeza para Estados Unidos y
también para Israel.
Fijaos.
(Tras la invasión norteamerica de Irak en
el año 2003, la Fuerza Quds se dedicó a
organizar, entrenar y armar a milicias que
no le pusieron las cosas nada pero que nada
faciles a los norteamericanos.
Irán ncluso instruyo a estas milicias en
el uso de explosivos sofisticados que logran
perforar el blindaje de los vehículos militares
y que han causado cientos de bajas entre las
tropas estadounidenses.
Milicias que por cierto hoy cuentan con decenas
y decenas de miles de efectivos y que luchan
ya por el control total de Irak.
Algo similar ha ocurrido en Afganistán, dónde
esta organización irani ha suministrado armas,
explosivos, equipos e incluso apoyo directo
a los talibanes para enfrentarse a las tropas
internacionales comandadas por Estados Unidos.
En 2006, el apoyo masivo a su plataforma libanesa,
a Hezbolla, hizo que por primera vez el ejercito
de Israel no ganará una guerra y se tuviera
que retitar tras una invasión desastrosa.
Más tarde en Siria, el apoyo masivo al regimen
de Al Asad ha sido clave para evitar su caida.
Y ahí no termina todo, en Yemen, las milicias
pro iranies han conseguido hacer frente al
poderoso ejercito saudi.
En Gaza la Fuerza Quds juega un papel clave
en el aprovisionamiento y entrenamiento de
Hamas.
Incluso han sido responsables de acciones
como esta:)
(Dos importantes instalaciones petroleras
sauditas fueron golpeadas por un ataque con
aviones no tripulados y Estados Unidos culpa
a Irán)
(Irán se apodera de un petrolero británico
en el Estrecho de Ormuz)
En otras palabras, la pérdida de Suleimani
ha sido un duro golpe para el régimen de
los ayatolas.
Todo un misil en su línea de flotación,
nunca mejor dicho.
El dron de Estados Unidos no sólo se llevó
por delante a la figura clave de la política
exterior y militar de Irán, sino que también
en cierto modo ha supuesto toda una humillación
para un país que en gran medida basa su política
exterior en dar miedo.
[Porque….
Vamos a ver, eso de que se lleven por delante
con un dron al responsable de tus servicio
de inteligencia y de tus cuerpos especiales…
pues que quereis que os diga no queda muy
bien, no dice mucho del nivel de esos grupos.]
(Es imposible exagerar la importancia de esta
acción en particular.
Es más significativa que el asesinato de
Osama bin Laden o incluso la muerte del líder
del Estado Islámico, Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
General David Petraeus, ex comandante de las
fuerzas estadounidenses en Irak y Afganistán
y ex director de la CIA)
Pero… amigos, llegados a este punto, la
pregunta obligada, la pregunta que nos tenemos
que hacer es…
¿Por qué Trump decidió llevar a cabo este
ataque?
¿Por qué desencadenar justo ahora semejante
crisis política y diplomática?
Atentos.
(LAS CLAVES TRAS LA DECISIÓN DEL PRESIDENTE
TRUMP)
Seamos sinceros, la animadversión y las ganas
de cargarse a este tipo no son algo nuevo
en Washington.
Practicamente todas las administraciones norteamericanas
han tenido en el punto de mira a Suleimani
desde que asumió el control de la Fuerza
Quds.
Sin embargo, hasta ahora nadie había querido
ir tan lejos.
Y la pregunta, es ¿Por qué Trump ha tomado
ahora la decisión de llevarselo por delante?
Aaaa… se que lo que algunos estáis pensando.
Te conozco.
¿Crees que vamos a decir que ha sido por
un impulso, una rabieta, una ida de olla del
presidente norteamericano?
Pues no, lo siento pero si piensas eso has
fallado.
Hay 3 razones que explican un ataque que ha
puesto la política internacional patas arriba.
Veréis, la primera tiene que ver con la situación
en Irak, que vive un entorno explosivo.
Desde hace meses el enfrentamiento entre partidarios
y detractores de la influencia irani en Irak
se ha desatado.
Hasta el punto de que Irán ha puesto el pie
en el acelerador para tratar de tomar el control
de su vecino.
De esta forma las milicias entrenados, financiadas
y dirigidas por Irán no solo se han enfrentado
y reprimido a las fuerzas opositoras sino
que también han empezado otra vez a hostigar
y atacar a las tropas estadounideses que por
supuesto apoyan a los sectores no proiranies.
¿Para qué?
Pues para conseguir que los americanos se
piren del país.
Eso es lo que explica, por ejemplo, los ataques
a las bases nortemaericanas que se han producido
en los últimos meses o el intento de asaltar
la mismisima embajada.
(Miles de manifestantes atacan la embajada
de EEUU en Bagdad al grito de "muerte a EEUU"
El Mundo)
Y toda apuntaba a que Suleimani se había
desplazo hasta Bagdad para organizar y coordinar
ataques masivos contra la presencia militar
norteamericana y preparar el asalto difinitivo
a las instituciones iraquíes.
(Soleimani estaba planeando ataques inminentes
y siniestros contra diplomáticos y personal
militar estadounidenses, pero lo atrapamos
en el acto y terminamos con él.
[...] Anoche tomamos medidas para detener
una guerra, no para comenzarla.)
La segunda explicación tiene que ver, precisamente,
con el año en el que estamos… 2020.
Y… ¿Qué hay en 2020?
Exacto, elecciones.
Y amigos, ¿qué es más popular en Estados
Unidos que acabar con todo un enemigo declarado?
Y si eso además ayuda a desviar la atención
del impechment o de la falta de resultados
en política exterior, mejor que mejor.
(Por último, el tercer motivo está relacionado
con esta falta de resultados.
Veréis, desde que llegó a la Casa Blanca
ha mantenido una política de presión creciente
hacía Iran para tratar de lograr sus objetivos
y que el regimen de los ayatolas hincará
la rodilla: Ahí tenemos la ruptura del acuerdo
nuclear o las sucesivas sanciones económicas
que se le han impuesto a Irán.
Pues bien, como nada de eso ha funcionado
ahora ha tocado ir un poco más alla, al tiempo
que este ataque permite que Estados Unidos
recobre un activo muy pero que muy importante
en política exterior: el peso de la disuasión,
es decir el miedo a las represalias.)
Pero, amigos, tras un ataque de semejante
magnitud la pregunta que todos nos hacemos
es… ¿Y ahora que puede ocurrir?
¿Estamos realmente a las puertas de una guerra
en Oriente Medio?
Atentos.
(LA VENGANZA)
Irán ha jurado venganza.
El golpe ha sido tan duro que el régimen
está en shock.
(“Los criminales que han manchado sus manos
con la sangre del general Soleimani y de otros
mártires en el ataque deben esperar una dura
venganza” Ali Jamenei, líder supremo de
Irán.)
(“Sin duda, la gran nación de Irán y otras
naciones libres de la región se vengarán
por este crimen del criminal Estados Unidos”.
Hasan Rohaní, Presidente de Irán)
El lanzamiento de al menos dos docenas de
misiles balísticos contra las bases iraquies
en Erbil y Al-Asad ha sido la primera respuesta
furiosa.
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que el régimen
de los Ayatolás está dispuesto a lanzarse
a toda una guerra contra el “imperio”.
Pues… con riesgo de equivocarme me atrevería
a decir que no.
Al menos no tendría sentido.
[Una cosa es querer venganza y otra muy diferente
es cavarte tu propia tumba.]
Y es que… no solo es una cuestión de capacidad
militar, que evidentemente lo es.
Si no que el fuerte de Irán es jugar de una
forma muy pero que muy diferente.
Que Irán va a vengar esta ataque lo saben
hasta en el reino de Tonga.
Dados los precedentes lo podemos considerar
casi como un hecho.
La pregunta era y es básicamente, ¿Cómo
demonios lo van a hacer?
(La República Islámica de Irán se niega
a tomar medidas emocionales y apresuradas.
Estableceremos un plan, pacientemente, para
responder a este acto terrorista de una manera
aplastante y poderosa.
Somos quienes establecemos la hora y el lugar
de nuestra respuesta recíproca.
General Abolfazl Shekarchi, portavoz de las
fuerzas armadas de Irán)
Y según parece eso es exactamente lo que
han hecho.
Sí, vale han disparado más de dos docenas
de misiles balísticos y han creado una alarma
enorme en todo el planeta…
Pero… Un momento porque puede que no todo
sea exactamente tal y como parece.
(En el momento de publicar este vídeo la
información que tenemos es que el ataque
se ha efectuado sobre dos instalaciones secundarias
para los Estados Unidos y que no ha causado
bajas en las filas del ejercito norteamerico.
Es decir, la Guardía Revolucionaria habría
escogido dos objetivos con los que darse golpes
en el pecho, reivindicarse, lanzar una enorme
campaña de marketing dentro de Irán, sembrar
el caos en el vecino Irak [Qué es lo que
quieren] Y al mismo reducir el riesgo de una
respuesta contundente de los Estados Unidos.
Algo así como tensar la situación para destensarla)
Aunque, ojo, porque esto no quiere decir que
aquí termina todo.
Y no hablo de Estados Unidos sino de Iran.
Y es que amigos, este país tiene un enorme
historial de combatir… sin hacer la guerra.
Es decir, sin soldados uniformados, tanques,
aviones, declaraciones, etcétera, etcétera.
Vamos, lo que es una guerra.
Pero… No, el fuerte de Irán no es nada
de eso sino actuar mediante la guerra asimétrica,
es decir, organizando ataques informales perpetrados
por grupos apoyados, entrenados y financiados
por Irán… pero que estrictamente no son
Irán.
De hecho, ese tipo de estrategias eran la
gran especialidad de Soleimani.
Es algo que el régimen de los ayatola ha
hecho desde siempre.
Como, cuando por ejemplo, en 1983 Hezbola
voló por los aíres un cuartel de los marines
de los Estados Unidos en el Libano, causando
más de 200 bajas.
O cómo cuando ayudo a Hezbollah volo la Embajada
de Israel o en Buenos Aires y el Centro Judio
más importante de Argentina en 1992.
(Pero no hace falta irse tan lejos.
Ahí están las milicias en Irak atacando
a los soldados estadounideses durante años.
Ataques que llevaron a cabo con explosivos
suministrados por Iran y que se calcula causaron
más de 600 bajas.
Por no hablar de Afganistán.
Actos cómo los que hemos visto en 2019 cuándo
Irán de forma directa o indirecta derribó
un dron estadounidese, cuando hostigó y retuvo
a petroleros en el estrecho de Ormuz o cómo
cuando en septiembre datacó las dos principales
instalaciones petroleras de Arabia Saudí.)
Así es como juega la Fuerz Quds.
Los propios cohetes que Hamas utiliza para
atacar Israel tienen su sello.
Y esa es exactamente la respuesta que podemos
esperar.
(Es una gran amenaza.
El hecho de que tengamos F-16 y F-35 no es
relevante para este problema ”. General
de brigada jubilado Yossi Kuperwasser, ex
jefe de la división de investigación en
la rama de Inteligencia Militar de la Fuerza
de Defensa de Israel.)
Las capacidades son tan diferentes que otro
escenario sería casi imposible.
Incluso aunque la Guardia Revolucionaria se
haya atrevido a lanzar los misiles balísticos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el tanque más
potente del ejército iraní es el T-72 ruso,
en funcionamiento desde comienzo de los 70.
Y siguen utilizando tanques que datan de la
guerra de Corea y la Guerra de Vietnam.
Y la situación de la fuerza aérea es aún
peor.
(Claro que todo podría cambiar con la reacción
de Estados Unidos.
Pero lo cierto es que una ocupación de Irán
no parece nada recomendable.
Podría convertirse en una pesadilla para
los Estados Unidos.
Hablamos de un país enorme, con cientos de
miles de soldados preparados para la batalla,
uno de los mejores sistemas de defensa antiaera
del planeta y miles de misiles de corto y
medio alcance que aunque no podrían atacar
a Estados Unidos si podrían hacerle mucho
daño a aliados como Israel, Emiratos o Arabia
Saudita.)
Así que salvo sorpresa mayúscula lo que
podemos esperar es mucha tensión y mucha
guerra asimétrica.
En fin amigos, así están las cosas.
Pero ahora turno para ti.
¿Crees que finalmente a pesar de todo veremos
una guerra entre Estados Unidos e Irán?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
ya sabes si este vídeo te la resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.